[Musique]
va légaliser ce que vous n'êtes jamais
un truc dans un taxi ou dans un über ou
un truc dans un tenant alors je suis
tombé sur un type dans un bear way qui
était en fête qui était je pense qu'ils
offraient à huy est en fait au départ
ils parlent autour d'eux au fresnoy
non mais je pense qu'en fait il avait
vraiment un maladie mentale le posez moi
c'est pas bien commencé à le faire
non mais il faut pas se mettre il a
commencé à parler normalement je lui ai
répondu qu'après il a changé de voie et
il m'a dit ouais mais bon alors tu es
comprend donc là j'ai compris qu'en fait
c'était une blague dont je me suis mise
à rire vous me connaissez je ris assez
facilement mais il a pris une troisième
voie non hélas gennady et laïta dis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention
plus ça va plus ça va aller vite
attention à ce que vous êtes prêts les
gars
[Applaudissements]
du coup j'ai dit que tant jeu finalement
je vais changer de destination je vais
m'arrêter là au feu et en fait il n'a
pas voulu le type n'a pas voulu il m'a
dit non et avec une avec la première
voile m'a dit non d'accord l'adresse
c'est celle là on va aller là d'accord
et donc la gg dira d'accord j'ai pensé
dans la journée vous oui on n'a rien de
très excitant chabat début de la phrase
de la semaine ne sont pas légion oui en
effet parce que oui et derrière votre
éducation suis allé dans un bocal agit
alors qu'elle est temps de le traiter
ensuite plus eu peur je vous repose le
dire les rockets reid mené pour les deux
côtés vont vivre les gars il à l'onu tu
sais je me dis alors un jour le taxi me
propose d'avoir des pur sang ni % de
réduction sur la course global mais en
contrepartie je dois m'arrêter
il doit s'arrêter un fast food à pour
aller récupérer après quand elle est
finie
[Applaudissements]
la table
j'avais pas compris c'est qu'en réalité
il faisait aussi de la livraison en plus
d'être un banal talons le gars m'a
expulsé lui taxi ah oui parce que j'ai
fait comme à paris c'est leur vie n'a
droit qu'à gauche prévoit 1 connaît la
route etc
j'ai parlé en anglais on était à londres
il m'a dit monsieur ça ne se fait pas il
m'adore et du taxi et s'il vous plaît
est ce qu'on a un tel une bonne histoire
c'est tout ce que je dois je ne demande
pas grand-chose bordel
[Applaudissements]
c'est toute cette culture locale à quai
saint sébastien dans le monde il va
rentrer ma mère alors j'avais une dette
un vote recul à la pâte humaine un taxi
alors ils essaient par tous et par un
taxi pas tout faire j'ai rencontré des
gens alors tout mais pas dans un taxi
alors elle est très courte anecdotes
rivoli
je montre dans le taxi judy boulogne
s'il vous plaît ml non je peux pas de
sac et tu dégages voilà
[Applaudissements]
sa course est la même c'est comme voilà
évidemment bisous aux frères et bien sûr
il ya en parle on ne veut pas de sac et
non mais pardon mais tu sais qu'on va
dans la même salle de sport que ce
monsieur nantes malick ba ouai mais
qu'on ne voit jamais non mais parce que
cette personne passe devant tout le
monde et va s'entraîner dans une pièce
secrète
on s'arrête on ne se voit jamais alors
que nous on te voit passer et mali qui
ne fait les textos médias locaux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]